how's it going res - beautifu and
welcome to another episode of more bus
more like a more was hahahahaha here -
here here we got a tester blood together
okay wow you just Wow look at your eyes
thank you I see see a problem with my
eyes yeah your eyes are really at issue
right I've seen a lot of shitty things
in my life I can tell that well just not
to look anymore
now Nick it looks like looking at my
penis and you were most impressed I'd be
really impressed if you had a penis to
be honest in my woman ha ha can I test
you you can trust me I am a woman with a
penis what's not the trust China you got
me there let's go trust people together
yeah let's see if other people happiness
I mean if I can trust them yeah yeah
that's the only way I trust okay
my mission is to go to the showers but
we should bury the middle wow it is fo
Nerdist Nikki hey hey hey are you racing
me okay y-you said you had to go to the
showers that nothing was there god
dammit it doesn't pop up right away you
just gave yourself away Rock so bad oh
hey hey hey hey what is your name I beg
you I beg you give oculus if they were
farming Sunday oh my god even putting
off the accent on me and stuff but Alec
how about this come may come back I just
so scary the accent is it is really
making me uncomfortable
hi I just want to play with your it
they're going to have fun you and I Abba
ABBA didn't play
many piece I will teach you you Swedish
mice yes somebody not play together okay
oh look it's our friends this is awkward
running from it sleep I don't know
well behind you my name is Martin like
my lining it's a pleasure to meet you
Martin wash your feet Ripple's get
Martin yeah what's your favorite boy
game am i poor gate what is it battle I
like when you say you sunk my battleship
that's my favorite journey sir
do I need tests on tears what's your
favorite board game oh it's my nose oh
yeah don't look at me like that you're
neat I think guys there's something odd
about Janita I feel the same thing oh
yeah
watch it this is a situation is
confusing to me thanks manly voice in my
head guide me to meet some even entity
has got into James correct whoa whoa
did someone do something just poke me
that was funny oh Jesus Anita you must
die well this is a yo uh the minx um I'm
sorry that is the lady quickly who was
it originally the alien boom get back
here oh yes did Lucas is looking out for
the group Justin and I yes okay whoa
whoa
look no no Dennis Dennis we gotta stick
together
yeah yeah I got this side of the door
you get the other anything come through
this door we have that force of our
anger okay and then there's no all right
Edward I'm sorry I just
this where are you
honey honey honey iris run just ride it
after me
I've got delicious at all I taste like
salad and bacon up
wait does look good like eat your [ __ ]
okay let's let's have a serious talk
here this is Roger together sure sure
okay so a bit clang all right we have to
find out who's a leaner or whatever by
asking each other a question sure
will it and if they I don't know we have
to put pressure on each other yeah yeah
okay and are you sorry okay uh Reggie oh
praise enough but that was pre
aggressive that was like that I might
know a little more pressure and our
intestines will fall outside sure she's
a shooter sir sir I'll take it down a
notch all right brandy yeah yeah brandy
are you an alien or what are you sure
it's ready that's too much pressure
hey hey hey I'm cool I'm cool I'm cool
hey you too [ __ ] get him all right
press hope you enjoy this episode if you
did go ahead and leave a like it helps
me out a lot and subscribe to become a
breath today I'll see you in the next
one hey awesome chilly already I just
get anxious
and I spot